[Música]
más de 1.300 personas fueron detenidas
en varias ciudades de Rusia mientras
participaban en protestas en contra de
la movilización militar parcial
decretada por Vladimir Putin 300.000
reservistas se unirán a la guerra en
Ucrania lo que también llevó a miles de
personas a intentar abandonar el país
Los tiquetes aéreos se agotaron
ante la asamblea general de la ONU el
presidente ucraniano voladimir selensky
exigió castigos contra Rusia por la
invasión de su país el mandatario
también solicitó a la creación de un
tribunal especial para juzgar a Moscú
por sus crímenes durante el evento el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
acusó a Rusia de querer borrar del mapa
a una nación soberana
nuevos problemas para el ex presidente
Donald Trump la fiscal general de Nueva
York Leticia James interpuso una demanda
civil contra Álex mandatario tres de sus
hijos y contra la organización Trump
acusándolos de fraude fiscal además por
decisión de un panel Federal de
apelaciones el departamento de Justicia
podrá retomar su investigación a los
documentos incautados en mar al lago
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias de
France 24 Mi nombre es Andrés Meza Muñoz
es un placer acompañarlos empezamos con
noticias de la guerra en Ucrania después
de haber sufrido pérdida significativas
en territorio ucraniano tras la contra
ofensiva lanzada por las fuerzas de kiev
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
decretó la movilización militar parcial
por lo que 300.000 reservistas con
experiencia en combate y servicios serán
enviados al frente en territorio
ucraniano se trata de una escalada en la
Guerra que inició el pasado 24 de
febrero cuando las fuerzas rusas
entraron a Ucrania escuchemos al
presidente ruso
creo que es necesario apoyar la
propuesta del Ministerio de defensa y el
Estado Mayor de realizar una
movilización militar parcial en Rusia
repito solo estamos hablando de una
movilización parcial solo a las personas
que están actualmente en la reserva
militar se dará prioridad a aquellos que
han servido las fuerzas armadas y tienen
una especialización militar particular y
la experiencia correspondiente antes de
ser enviados a servir los reclutados
tendrán capacitación a obligatoria
apoyándose en la experiencia adquirida
durante la operación militar especial el
decreto sobre la movilización parcial se
ha firmado frente a la asamblea general
de Naciones Unidas el presidente
ucraniano de manera virtual para pedir
un castigo justo para Rusia por la
invasión de su país entre otras cosas
pidió que le sea retirado a Rusia el
derecho al veto en el Consejo de
Seguridad de la ONU escuchemos
Ucrania exige un castigo porque se
intenta robar nuestro territorio castigo
por el asesinato de miles de personas
las acciones contra el agresor forman
parte de la fórmula de paz bloquear el
comercio y las relaciones con el agresor
forman parte de la fórmula de paz todo
ello ya forma parte del castigo Mientras
que el agresor sea parte de la toma de
decisiones en las organizaciones
internacionales no podremos avanzar
habrá que aislarlo mientras que dure la
invasión hay que rechazar el derecho al
voto
hay que quitarle los derechos a la
delegación retirarles el derecho al veto
cuando se trata de un miembro del
Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU
los ciudadanos del Estado agresor no
pueden ir de turismo de compras en el
territorio de aquellos que valoran la
paz sino que hay que alentarles a través
de las restricciones de la emisión de
visados a luchar contra la agresión de
su propio estado hay que castigar por
alimentar el mal
[Música]
la guerra en Ucrania también fue
abordada por el presidente
estadounidense Joe biden durante la
segunda jornada de la asamblea general
de las Naciones Unidas en Nueva York
levantario no solo desestimó los
argumentos de Rusia para atacar a los
ucranianos sino que también se pronunció
sobre el anuncio de los referendos en
regiones controladas por Moscú en
Ucrania
hablemos claramente un miembro
permanente del Consejo de Seguridad de
las Naciones Unidas invadió a su vecino
intentó borrar a un estado soberano del
mapa Rusia ha violado descaradamente los
principios fundamentales de la carta de
las Naciones Unidas ninguno más
importante que la Clara prohibición de
tomar el territorio de su vecino por la
fuerza el mundo debería ver estos actos
escandalosos por lo que son
Putin afirma que tuvo que actuar porque
Rusia estaba amenazada pero nadie
amenazó a Rusia
y en otros temas de la segunda jornada
de la asamblea general de Naciones
Unidas otro de los participantes del
evento fue el canciller de Cuba Bruno
Rodríguez El funcionario arremetió
contra Estados Unidos al acusarlo de
disuadir a otros gobiernos e
instituciones de hacer negocios con el
gobierno de La Isla Rodríguez también
instó a Washington a resolver problemas
que conducen a la migración ilegal
vamos alertado claramente
al gobierno de los Estados Unidos
de que deben solucionarse los factores
que alientan la migración y regular y
provocan pérdidas de vidas como el
incumplimiento por su parte desde el
de la obligación según acuerdos
bilaterales vigentes de otorgar no menos
de 20.000 Visas anuales para migrantes
la existencia de la ley de ajuste cubano
el trato privilegiado con motivación
política las presiones restrictivas
sobre países de tránsito regular y el
bloqueo económico reforzado que en
Estados Unidos este miércoles la fiscal
general de Nueva York Leticia James
interpuso una demanda civil contra
Donald Trump tres de sus hijos y contra
la organización Trump son señalados de
inflar deliberadamente el valor de sus
activos con el fin de hacer tratos
favorables de aseguradoras y bancos
problemas legales para Donald Trump y
también para su familia después de que
la fiscal general de Nueva York Leticia
James presentará una demanda civil por
sobrevalorar sus activos y patrimonio
exigimos a Trump y a su organización que
se deshagan de los beneficios
financieros obtenidos a través de las
prácticas fraudulentas persistentes
estimados en al menos 250 millones de
dólares
según la fiscalía Donald Trump y la
empresa Trump organization infló Su
riqueza en miles de millones para
obtener condiciones más favorables para
sus transacciones como tasas de interés
más bajas y seguros más baratos una
denuncia además de 200 páginas en la que
también figuran tres hijos de Trump
Donald Trump Junior Eric Trump e ivanka
Trump así como los ejecutivos de la
empresa acusaciones que Trump ha negado
de plano acusando a la fiscal negra de
racismo otra casa de brujas por parte de
una fiscal general lista Leticia James
que fracasó en su carrera para
gobernadora obteniendo un apoyo casi
nulo del público este es uno de los
muchos entramados legales que se
amontonan sobre su figura como la
investigación penal a por su acción
contra las elecciones presidenciales del
2020 o la investigación Federal sobre la
posesión de registros presidenciales
clasificados la fiscal James Lleva más
de tres años investigando la empresa de
Trump y cuenta con puentes cercanas al
ex presidente
Fue llamado a testificar el 10 de agosto
cuando se acogió más de 400 veces a su
derecho de no autoincriminarse negando
todos los cargos en otras noticias de
Estados Unidos una corte de apelaciones
permitió al departamento de Justicia
reanudar la revisión de los documentos
incautados de la casa del ex presidente
Donald Trump en Florida y que son
clasificados como Ultra secretos
previamente hablamos con Rafael peñalver
analista político y abogado en derecho
constitucional y bienes raíces de
Estados Unidos sobre Qué significa este
nuevo revés para Trump
peligrosísimo peligrosísimo porque el
hecho de que se hayan llevado estos
documentos tan secretos de la Casa
Blanca eso en sí es un delito la gran
pregunta es por qué se llevaron esos
documentos Por qué no solamente se los
llevó sino que insistió en retener
control de esos documentos después de
que el departamento de Justicia se lo
pidió a las buenas después de que una
corte Federal le mandara una orden
judicial para que los entregara porque
sus abogados falsificaron una
declaración jurada diciendo de que todos
los documentos ya se habían llevado
demarolago y después cuando vino la el
allanamiento del 8 del 8 de agosto pues
se encontraron cientos de documentos que
todavía permanecían y algunos de ellos
En el buró personal del ex presidente
Trump en una gaveta donde estaban
también sus pasaportes y pertenencias
más más personales por lo tanto eso
indica una directa conocimiento directo
del expresidente con este delito que se
acusa que se daba cometiendo algo que lo
implica él directamente que podíamos ver
la presentación de un de cargo de
penales de cargos criminales
hasta que es informativa en 24 Gracias
por acompañarnos
[Música]